me and the director Mike White are
sitting there going that's average
are you curious about what really goes
on behind the scenes at the White Lotus
we're here to spill all the secrets from
Theo James's special prosthetic Jennifer
coolidge's voyeurism and Aubry Plaza's
deep connection with her character
Harper is this weird you know lucky
moment number one you know what we're
talking about here the scene where Aubry
Plaza's character Harper secretly
watches as Theo James's character
Cameron gets undressed who else was
watching we'll let you know in just a
minute so there's a lot to unpack here
but one thing at the top of our list was
the prosthetic he wore Theo told the
makeup designer he didn't want it to be
distracting in any way she's got like a
hammer or something like I mean it's
bigger than that it's actually stole it
off a donkey in the field number two
only open to a select few something we
found pretty hilarious was Jennifer
coolidge's enthusiasm for the white
lotus's spicy scenes White Lotus 2 has
way more sex it wasn't common for other
cast members to be on set for those
scenes I mean they said it's a closed
set but I was able to get in number
three where do we score an invite not
only do they get to party on set but it
doesn't stop even after they've wrapped
for the day check out this video of
Jennifer Coolidge and SD hayam dancing
to Mamma Mia and try to tell us you
don't have major fomo it's very very fun
yeah there's no bad side
to this one number four she was
constantly playing them on set mostly
because she found herself pretty bored
obviously she spent most of her time
working but otherwise she was just stuck
inside a hotel about a month in she took
the read diffusers in a hallway and set
them up into a large Blair Witch style
symbol in the middle of Adam DeMarco's
dressing room she even went as far as to
do the same thing in her own dressing
room and freaking out to other co-stars
so she wouldn't get caught then she
started slipping papers with ominous
messages under everyone's doors Adam
DeMarco was absolutely terrified he went
and asked the hotel to look up security
footage and they identified me on the
cameras number five it wasn't what you
think it was when the cast arrived in
Sicily to film the show naturally they
expected the weather to be nice and hot
it wasn't they even had to go so far as
buying winter jackets just to remain
remain on set we got here and it's been
freezing cold and everyone's bought
puffer jackets number six Sabrina and
pachetore had big shoes to fill as
Valentina before shooting started she
couldn't sleep at all because she was so
nervous to live up to Armand's Legacy as
Resort manager I was reading articles
about how genius he was and I thought I
would like to go back in the womb of my
mom it was even to the point where she
was crying real tears to her mother on
the phone out of fear her mother quickly
though brought her back down to earth so
she could bring Valentina to life she
said now you stop it you just do your
job this is your life number seven Aubry
Plaza's most personal role yet Mike
White has a knack for taking people's
personal traits and vulnerabilities and
putting them into his characters Jason
took every weird thing about me and made
it into Tanya it's probably one of the
reasons the show is such a huge success
that was just something that I think he
kind I had in his back pocket when he
wrote Harper Mike and Aubry have been
friends for a really long time so he
knew exactly how to write her into the
character I felt like a very very much
related to Harper
um in a lot of ways so it felt a little
bit closer to home number eight did you
know it was originally much more
explicit what makes that particular
scene so tantalizing is the fact that we
as the audience aren't totally sure what
Cameron's true intentions were that
wasn't always the way the scene played
out originally we shot and it was a bit
more it was more intense than we were
saying it was more you know it wasn't
until actually seeing it played out that
Mike wanted to rework it number nine you
know Mike White was on Survivor right in
the season 2 opening scene the women on
the beach chairs next to Megan feji were
cast members of Survivor with Mike at
the time their names are Cara and
Angelina we are so excited number 10
Mike used his relationship with his
father as an inspiration for the second
season the story between Birch and
Dominic was Loosely based on Mike's
experience taking his own father to
Sweden where their family is from this
family tracing their roots and and
ancestry and stuff in the Homeland
number 11. how much money it is to stay
at the actual hotel for a night the
second season of White Lotus was filmed
all over the Sicilian cities of Palermo
and Noto as well as the surrounding
ionian sea there were several scenes
shot in the town of fumer Fredo also
famous for being featured in The
Godfather the hotel they filmed at was
actually San Domenico Palace part of the
luxurious Four Seasons Hotel chain rooms
start at around 500 and go up to about 7
000 per night if you are three this is
going to be an extra charge really
number 12 the methods are completely
different Sabrina and pachetore has
always studied with American acting
coaches so she never felt completely
comfortable doing Italian projects the
method of working is different the
approach is different being on the set
of White Lotus was a major game changer
for her as far as her career with Mike
White's personal touches Aubry Plaza's
incredible character development and
hilarious Prosthetics season 2 is
definitely one to remember what's your
favorite behind the scenes moment